one hour more per day on my core three I
begin this every year first move I need
to identify what are the core three
things right now that have been bringing
me results this year the core three
things so as an example in my business I
go okay what are the three primary
revenue drivers we have right now
because just like you if you're in
marketing you've probably tested a lot
of things throughout the early part of
the year the spring even in early part
of the summer so my question is what's
been working and I mean absolutely
working what are the three absolute best
things they're working for you in your
business or your career or your personal
life if you're not employed or not
self-employed what's with the three
things that are so working for you I
want you to know what those three things
are and overall I want you to give an
hour every day more to a focus of one
two or three all three of those things
need motivation watch the top 10 of
believe Nation because I love it hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Brendan burchard and my take
on his top 50 rules of success enjoy
let me give you an example right now in
in my business right one of my core
three is our book funnel like so for me
as you guys know as an author and a
trainer when I sell books that's good
for the business we sell books then
people want online courses then they
want to come to our seminars then
someday they might join our program like
we're doing here our Live Events or our
masterminds or they might hire us for a
coach or they might hire for me for
speaking but the book is a big core
three for the business right and so
right now I go okay I need every single
day
the rest of this year to give more time
to that thing
every day not on a Wednesday not on a
set like every day I need to check in
the numbers create a new ad flip out a
page I need to lead my team better on it
something every day
for that one thing
make sense
so if you got three things what I want I
want an hour more so I mean it might be
in 20 minutes 20 minutes you know and
you know 20 minutes
so you're giving 20 minutes more each
day or maybe you just choose one and
you're gonna give that an hour more a
day but it's basically this one more
work hour of the day focused on one of
the core three got it write it down
and this for you I want you to start
this
today
if that means you're watching this in
Munich Germany and we finish this
tonight and you stay stay up one more
hour I'm like cheers man do that but
it's like today for those of you who are
here in the US in this time zone I'm
like today one more hour on focusing I
often call the the core three or the
needle movers the primary three things
that are working I need an hour more
from you a day for the rest of the year
and you will thank me
for the next decade you're like oh my
God Brandon because what happens is and
you know this
you're getting caught up in distraction
and so right now people will relax
daysical and they're not focused on the
right things
so I want you to think where are you
distracted I want you to clear out the
distractions I want you to say the core
three things in my business are
and I need you to give an hour or more a
day on those
that's it if you'll start that now and
you'll punch in that hour more every day
until Thanksgiving I promise your
Christmas will be unbelievable
confidence is your belief in your
ability to figure things out
now often you cheat yourself because you
think well no confidence is I've done
everything I need to do in the world and
I have all the successes and I'm on the
cover of magazines and I'm rich and we
we tell ourselves I'll have confidence
when
but if you're going to change your life
you need to right now adopt a more
confident mindset and say you know what
I mean I don't have to know everything
in the world I don't want to be the most
successful person on the Block what I
need to do is believe in myself and
believe in my ability to figure things
out give me enough time energy resources
mentorship study I can achieve my dreams
that's where it really begins belief in
our ability to figure things out now of
course at a deep psychological level we
know that confidence is all about your
sense of worth
your sense of capability or ability to
do things and your belief also in not
only yourself but your future
and let me say those couple things too
worth
ability future
if you don't believe you're worth
anything obviously your competence is
there if you don't believe you're able
to go do anything obviously your
confidence is there psychologists often
call this self-efficacy right you just
don't feel like you can you know be
efficacious or be a person who gets
things done in the world because you
don't believe in your ability and last
companies has a lot to do with your
perception of where you'll be in the
future if you think you're gonna be
broke and a loser in the future
obviously you're not going to go for it
today right if you don't see if you see
yourself as lonely and an outcast in the
future you're obviously not going to
walk up to her or him and say hey how
you doing in my industry as I came in
the thought leader industry we call it
which is you know author speaker coach
seminar leader life coach business coach
or online trainer or online thought
leader social media thought leader in
that culture which we just call it the
thought leader industry when I came into
it everything was Outsourcing everyone
says Outsource Outsource Outsource don't
need to do video Outsource it don't need
to do audio Outsource it don't need to
learn how to manage your stage career
Outsource it everybody said Outsource
everything but I was like you know what
that's just not true
in every given career
there is a set of skills
that you have to master and develop into
if you're going to become excellent at
what you do if you're going to become
the highest paid in your company or
highest paid in your industry or highest
paid in your field you have to dial it
in and understand what are the skills
I'm working on
you hear me say this before at I
Performance Academy like if I parachute
it into your house right now or onto
your roof and then climb down and go to
your house if I came in your house and I
actually looked at your calendar will
you opened up your laptop we looked at
your calendar
could I see in your calendar over the
next couple months
clear block time
that you've designated towards
developing the skills that are necessary
for you to win
like is it in your calendar
or are you just gonna Outsource it
and you really have to know what those
skills are you know for what I was doing
people told me at the very beginning of
my career Brandon you don't need to
learn video why would you learn video
just hire a videographer or a filmmaker
right off the bat I said well one I just
started my career I'm what you call
broke
I don't have the ability to just go hire
people I know some of you guys are
watching this and you're like I don't
have the ability to hire 10 15 20 people
but everyone tells me just go hire
people sometimes you need to develop the
skills to do everything in your business
until you get the amount of Revenue
where you know you can hire somebody and
maintain their monthly retainer or
maintain their salary and that was true
for me when I first began people like
just Outsource get a videographer I'm
like I don't have the money for that so
I went out and I bought a cheap you know
uh what do they call those things flip
video camera do you remember those
there's a little flip video camera and I
set it up in boxes in my girlfriend's
apartment and I took a little flip video
camera and I didn't know how to use it
so I had to teach myself how to use it
and then I went around I tied it to the
box with duct tape around this box and I
put little notes next to it and I would
have to get up and go press the record
button come back and like ha I ran
inverse yard and I'd know I was like
freaked out I didn't even know how to do
what I was doing
but I learned how to take that video out
I learned how to upload it I learned how
to edit it I learned how to put in Sound
and Music and graphics and all these
things it took forever back then and I
had no idea to do it so I would be up
two three four in the morning teaching
myself how to do it
people also said also well Brandon just
hire a marketing manager to send your
emails out and build your newsletter
list I was like I don't have any money
to do that
Brandon hire somebody to do your online
marketing was like I I don't know I
don't have any money to do that
but here's the other side of it
it wasn't this I didn't have the money
to do it I also had the foresight to
realize these were going to be critical
skills to my future
what are the critical skills that would
be necessary for your future
you have to figure that out I didn't
Outsource marketing because like if if I
don't learn marketing
see marketing is always going to be a
piece of my future isn't it
so I said I had better learn to master
marketing it's always going to be
something I have to do in my career
what's the skill that you're always
going to have to know and do and I want
you to dive deep in it I want you to
dork out in it don't you get excited
about it I would spend hours and hours
and hours researching things trying
things learning about things that I had
no skill in because we live in a world
that's telling this huge lie and this
lie is hey you know what just follow
your passions just do what you're
naturally good at just follow your
strengths
and I'm like well sometimes your
strengths are insufficient
to build the business you need to build
sometimes what you're naturally good at
just because you're good at it and you
like it and you have passion for it
isn't what's required to actually build
and sell and do
I'm not saying don't follow your
strengths I'm saying don't rely on your
strengths
you know the truth is your mission and
your dream
should never be made to bow down to your
limited strengths you want to know how
you become Unstoppable
you learn that the energy you have is
not an accident
and you learn that the energy you have
is even the way it works I always use
this metaphor the power plant doesn't
have energy
it generates energy
the power plant doesn't have energy it
generates energy what does that mean
well what a power plant does is it it
draws energy from one resource
and it transforms it to a higher
utilization of energy
and then transmits it to the world
you have that same opportunity you don't
have to wait for happiness to arrive one
day you don't have to wait for good
energy to arrive one day you can
architect that into your mind and into
your body you don't have to hope one day
to feel more joyous you learn to bring
the joy you bring the joy you bring the
joy to the Morning Light you bring the
joy to your family you bring the joy to
the dinner table you bring the joy to
that team who sometimes
and you show up with a positive mindset
every day and they're like who is this
person and you know what when they call
you annoying or they call you
inauthentic or they call you too happy
or a stupid Optimist or whatever you
take the joy that you're part of a rare
set of human beings who would spend
their day like this working on ourselves
and growing because you know what you
want to get Believers in your life get
some momentum with a good attitude and
all of a sudden they start coming around
when they like oh wow you're different
and you're right you yes I am because
you worked for it because you knew life
was sure you knew it was short and you
decided at some point in your life hey
there's only so much time let me show up
with greater intention let me deal with
these struggles fat just head on you can
do this courageously and you decide to
bring the joy because life is short and
like me I hope you want to
earn
this life also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there you
have to have a process
every single week
where you let go
of the scrubs of the week
see what most people do is they just
carry the screw-ups hate myself failure
screw up label screw up label screw up
label screw up label and all the
mess-ups of their life they start
defining as themselves
and the mistake you made weeks ago you
labeled it as part of your identity
versus a behavioral mistake
it's right behaviors change every day
your behaviors today are different than
they were yesterday like behaviors are
very adaptive and reactionary type of
thing you'll get some behaviors wrong
some behavior is right but what most
people do is they get the wrong behavior
and they pull that wrong behavior and
they pull it into identity
mess up they grab the mess up
and they make it their mindset
no the mess up was a behavioral problem
is an identity problem
and so they take the mess up the problem
and they make it the personhood
and that's what we call making mountains
out of mohills like so what you got the
project in late does that mean you're a
complete failure no it means you got the
project in late dude next time plan
better Jesus
right it's like we take it we take the
little things and we blow it up into Who
We Are Who You Are
is not all the mess-ups it's part of
your Learning Journey but it's not you
and so you got to know like there's a
difference here
and sometimes baggage is recognizing oh
that was an awkward weird uncomfortable
harmful situation but that's not me
that was a situation it was a behavior
it was something that happened an
occasion and then we can go okay if
that's true then who am I really
who do I want to be
who am I now at this age of my life
without those old stories
and you got to give yourself
that distinction but here's the thing I
told you you need a reminder it needs to
be a rhythm for you it's part of my
Sunday Rhythm some of you guys know I do
my Sunday review and when I do my Sunday
review I literally go okay where could I
have shown up better this last week
where could I behave better this last
week what could I have done better this
last week and I just reflect on previous
week
and identify the things that didn't go
the way I wanted to and I asked okay
what could I have done and then I do the
most simple and basic thing that you
could do on a Sunday
I forgive myself
and I let it go a healthy response
is health
people ask me often well how do I deal
with this well I go be healthy
and what I mean by that is specifically
when you know you're disappointed when
you know you're sad when you know you've
got major setbacks you have to delay the
response to order 10 gallons of pad thai
okay you just have to you you cannot be
like you know what I feel terrible so
bust out the three bottles of wine here
we go you have to delay the response
that is unhealthy
does that make sense it's super easy I
mean it's crazy easy to when you are
having a down day or you're feeling
disappointed to go oh my gosh
um and go wreck yourself and get
exhausted so what happens you're
disappointed or you have a major setback
you know what you want to do sometimes
your response High performers is
overwork
you're sad so what do you do you
overwork or there's a major setback so
you know I'm gonna work 24 7 for nine
months and you basically kind of kill
yourself working and so in that way you
say but I'm getting ahead no actually
all of productivity science and all
well-being science proves over and over
and over again you compromising your
sleep and overworking yourself is
actually making your decisions be poorer
it's making your reactions to other
people be less sensitive less helpful
you're worse at negotiating you're worse
at closing sales you're worse at
Effectiveness in your own time of doing
basic tasks you're worse everything
everything that has to do with
leadership and progress and Human
Relationships you're worse at when you
cope by overworking
that's what we do I'm disappointed so
I'm going to work harder I'm mad so I'm
going to work harder uh the business
isn't doing well so I'm going to work
harder but if you overwork yourself that
is not a healthy response the first
thing I want you to figure out is what
is the business or the brand or the
company you're really trying to build
over the long term
and I know that sounds like yeah no
doubt Brandon common sense but many of
you you're entrepreneurs your stay at
home you're maybe a stay-at-home mom and
you're working on building that side
brand or that side hustle you're out in
the marketplace and maybe you're already
doing something where you're kind of
fully committed to it but kind of not
because you've got this other safe job
over here maybe you're somebody who just
started and you're not even sure what
you're supposed to be doing yet the
wrong time to hire is when you don't
know what you're supposed to be doing
yet you don't know the business model
and you don't know where you want to be
in three four five years it's really
important for you to get clarity before
you hire and I know that's so common
sense but it's not common practice
and a lot of people hire too soon and
then what happens is because they didn't
know the business model or they didn't
know what they really wanted
they got in a place where they had a lot
of team or that first virtual employee
that first assistant and they were all
kind of running around like what do we
what do we do what are we here for and
you didn't even have Clarity on your
purpose or your mission or your ambition
for the business
and that's not where we want to be
because I think the most important thing
is when you're going to hire and build a
high performing team is that you have
commitment for your future
you have Clarity when you are hiring you
are not hiring because you have a side
hustle you're not hiring because you
have a hobby you're hiring because you
have a clear mission
and your commitment to that is
everything because you're going to ask
people come on your team who they're
committing their life they're committing
their day they're committing their
mortgage payment their rent payment to
you there's a responsibility in you
hiring that you've got to know what
you're hiring for and that is so
critical I see people do that all wrong
all the time friends in Silicon Valley
they get a bunch of investment they hire
10 people they don't know what their 10
people are going to do they didn't know
the business model they ran out of
Revenue and they had those people on for
a year or two and then they ran out of
cash and that'll let them go I don't
want you to be in that position so the
right time to hire is always when first
you've defined that mission that goal
that business that dream for that three
five year out plan
and then you know that you're fully
committed and you're going to work it
and then you also really take joy in
leading and managing people because the
truth is you can Outsource a lot of
things and not have to deal with it or
you say listen I'm going to make sure
when I hire I hire well I look at
everything I'm doing right now
everything for my business right now and
I go okay
of all these things I'm doing
which ones will lead to significant
growth
this year
which ones will lead to significant
growth this year
everything else everything else I start
pushing out on the calendar whether I
push it out two three four months from
now or I push it till next year
but I do a real close look at all of my
activities I look at my Partnerships my
relationships I look at everything I'm
doing in terms of marketing funnels or
brand building or when I'm doing the
marketplace or when I'm doing my career
and I go which ones of these things are
leading to significant growth and if
it's not leading significant growth
I need to minimize that time
now I know you might say well what's the
difference between like a core 3 and a
significant growth rule
well the significant growth rule is for
the rest of the year right the core
three you already know the core 3 are
the three things you're already doing to
getting results
the significant growth rule is all these
new ideas people are going to give you
and put on your plate in August and
September and October November
everyone's going to give you some more
things too right there's going to be new
opportunities and every new opportunity
or every new idea your thing has to be
at this time of year will that lead to
significant growth this year if it is
maybe you can add that on to your
workload because remember I'm just
asking for an hour here
maybe you can add that on but if a
project comes your way and it doesn't
lead to significant growth at this stage
of the year and it won't lead to
significance growth the rest of this
year I'm out
I'm out so I turned down two or three
projects just last night from people
good ideas great ideas but I know those
won't lead to significant growth until
next year so I'm like not till next year
because I know that instead if I focus
on these things the core 3
or other projects that I do know lead to
significant growth in other words
significant growth is a way for you to
prioritize and say no
I don't want you taking on any new
projects at this stage of the year if
you don't believe they'll lead to real
growth by the end of the year because
you could just focus on these more right
it's that old story of Acres of the
diamonds you know people travel all
around the world looking for the
treasure and working so hard looking for
the new new thing and then they come
home and one day they put the Spade in
the backyard and they dig up some
diamonds
right often your next big breakthrough
you already it's already in your yard
you know what I tell people all the time
you've probably already met the person
who's going to help you generate your
next hundred thousand dollars
your next million dollars
like you already met they're already in
your network but you're spending all
this time to go do all these other
things you all you already met the
person who's gonna make you your next
million dollars or give you access to an
audience or give you access to an
opportunity you've already met the
person
but you're out there searching for new
and you're accepting all these new ideas
and as you accept new ideas as a high
performer what does that do that crowds
out other things
and so from this day forward until the
end of the year
I want you to have the significant
growth rule will this project lead to
significant growth by the end of the
year if not table it if you want to feel
in purpose one way to do that is to
recognize
kids are watching to recognize your
family is watching to recognize the
community is watching the neighborhood
is watching the world is watching us
right now history is taking note there
was a scorecard happening right now
based on how we are all showing up and
for some people that terrifies them
because like oh my gosh we're sharing up
terribly not me how about you how are
you showing up
the one of the greatest things I've ever
noticed from the exceptional people I
work with and Coach I mean like this is
like amazing people if I'm I'm training
a uh you know an Oprah Winfrey in her
team or I am you know talking to you
know some of the most like powerful
influencers in the world or I'm talking
with other people who are just like
so we're all Amazed by guess what they
always reveal a desire to be a role
model for others
when you desire to be a role model for
others it puts you into that pocket of
service in life
it makes you go oh my gosh I I want to
not just live the best of who I am
that's part of being a role model but I
want to live the best of who I am
because I want to give others permission
to do that themselves I want to share my
authentic voice so others can share
their authentic voice I want people to
see me volunteering because I want
people to go volunteer I want people to
see me being kind because I want people
to be and live when we're in a kind
world that is the role model mindset
you know and I so hope for you I I I so
hope for you that you will adopt the
role model mindset this year you don't
quote-unquote just have fun you have to
generate fun as you heard me say over
and over and over before the power plant
doesn't have energy it transforms and
generates energy if you want more fun in
your life you're gonna have to generate
more fun you're gonna have to have more
of attention and intention to create fun
and silly and ridiculous and humorous
and just joyous moments so what are some
ways you can do that well first and
foremost realize most great fun in life
comes from an immersion in the moment it
requires presence you know it's like so
many people are so their attention is a
million different places but have you
ever been in a restaurant and you got
your four or five friends around and you
all are just riffing like you're just
having fun you're all kicking around
ideas and telling funny stories and the
phones are off they're you know it just
the four or five of you gathered around
or maybe the two or three of you gather
around telling stories and you're all
immersed in that moment in immersion Joy
arises in an immersion uh you know humor
can perpetuate in immersion in the
moment in presence of the now you have
access to a greater level of energy and
awareness all around you that now you
can really translate transform into fun
so you have to begin by having an
intention each day say I'm going to be
present in my moments today I've been
present in everything that I do present
in my conversations with people present
in the tasks that I do because in that
presence more passion can come to a
light and more fun can be had it begins
with having intention to immerse here's
what the 45 day quit rule is and it's
hard for me I hate this one
I look at all my big project ideas you
know I don't know about you but I have a
journal with all my big ideas in it you
know or my vision board or I have an
Excel spreadsheet of all these different
ideas and projects I want to do and I've
got like you know right as an example
right now I know my next six books I'm
going to write
I know I know my next three campaigns
I'm gonna launch I know them
but here's what I have to force myself
to do and I don't like it
I say okay if this is a major project
that I want to do
even if it could lead to significant
growth
if I'm not going to start it listen to
this if I'm not going to start it in the
next 45 days
it's off my plate until next year
and I push it to 2019. I literally just
take it from my journal
in my little bucket of things I want to
do this year and I put it out into 2019
and I feel so mentally relieved
a lot of people have a lot of anxiety
about the number of projects they have
on their plate that they really want to
do
and so what ends up happening is that
anxiety leads to a lot of
procrastination
that anxiety leads to a lot of poor
prioritization because there's so much
to do they're like oh my God there's so
much to do here so I won't do any of it
ever had that have you ever found
yourself in front of Netflix going oh my
God I have so much to do but I just
watched the fourth video in the third
season has that ever happened
you have so much to do and that's the
problem you have so much to do that you
haven't prioritized what you are going
to do so you don't do anything
so what I do is this time of year I look
at all those things around my plate and
I get honest
which ones am I going to start in the
next 45 days
and if I'm not going to start the next
45 day well put it in 2019. now it's not
even on my mental concern it's not on my
dashboard no anxiety there no oh my God
I still got to get that one in nope it's
gone that's the 45 day quit rule I
encourage you to challenge yourself to
try it you need to know what moves the
needle in your business and higher to
that not just what you like you need to
know what skills are necessary for your
future and develop that not just what
you're naturally good at and this is
where people fail all the time
they're just trying to play in their own
lane but once you step into the role of
a business owner or you step into the
role of leader it's no longer about just
your passions you have a responsibility
it's called stewardship you have
stewardship to your team to their
mortgages to their rent you have
stewardship to your company now you have
stewardship to the Future you really
have to step into the identity of CEO
even if that's not what you're about
but I've learned so long working with
entrepreneurs some of them just never
step into the identity they need to
assume to win they never stepped into
I'm the CEO now I'm in charge
so they kind of half-assed it they kind
of like hobby it they're not really in
that role where they've defined this is
who I am I'm in charge of building this
if I don't it all falls apart and take
it upon themselves to say I have to lead
here well I have to do well here because
if they don't do that
guess what no one else is going to do it
for them if you know your person of
excellence and if it's true
I would not see a rhythm of crashing and
burning I would not see a rhythm of
Burns and busts burning out
failures and exhaustion
and it's really hard because I know
trust me I like there's so many nights
I'm like oh my God
if I just stay awake for four more hours
I can get these projects done and you
know what and then I'm a complete idiot
72 hours later I know it will catch up
with me
those who play the long game don't
compromise in the short game because
they know it catches up later and that
catch-up is a devil it is a bear it is a
beast it knocks you down and what
happens is you oh compromise three hours
here
but then because that compromise three
hours here you're knocked off your feet
three days over here
so if you'd take in the three hours to
recharge you wouldn't be worthless for
three days in the middle of the week
right I want you to have steady Rhythm
that's what we call high performance
that ability to have long-term success
while maintaining your well-being
and your health my friends you so
deserve that double down on your
goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 2020 you want to find purpose
this year double down on your goodness
adopt the role model mindset and say how
can I be a role model how can I serve
how can I do more good in the world
because as I do more good in the world I
lift the world as I do more good in the
world it challenges me to be a person of
potential and as I challenge myself to
be a person of potential and I Inspire
other people I feel like I am serving a
purpose
see when we set some role models to
others
purpose is connected in that very moment
when you know you're being a role model
you create boom purpose is connected
for your team boom purpose is connected
when you're standing on stage and you're
speaking your truth boom purpose is
connected you don't have to go hope to
find it it's connected when you are
being a role model it's connected when
you are activating your full potential
it's connected when you are in alignment
with your truth you got it you have to
go look for it you need to connect to it
what are the skills you have to develop
for me that was video for me that was
online marketing including building web
pages starting newsletters sending out
newsletters building opt-in pages to
capture name and emails following up
with sequences automated marketing
sequences I had to learn how to do that
I had to learn how to do webinars and
all these other things not because I
wanted to but I thought am I always
gonna do webinars in my business
probably how to learn how to do them
not because I had a passion for it I was
like I'm always going to do them so let
me figure it out first try it out first
do some research there's plenty of
things online that will help me figure
that out and then after that then I can
go into
hiring somebody else because I can
manage it so first piece develop the
skills needed to win and if you don't
know what those skills are or those
skills don't currently exist in your
calendar meaning you're developing them
then
you're just going through the motions
you're winging it and frankly you're
risking your career
one of my favorite things to do to check
to see if I got a high performer in the
midst when I talk with people I go what
are the three skills you're working on
right now in developing
and if they don't know it I know they're
amateurs but just it there's just
amateurs they're beginners and that's
not to judge them that's just to say
they haven't stepped into living what we
call the high performance experience the
high performance experience is all about
developmental goals it's all about
bringing our best and growing into what
we need to your daily G3 journal and
review uh if you've heard me teach a lot
about down times before uh especially in
the last couple years a couple years ago
the the G3 was the three G's and it's
what it means is every single day I want
you to journal on these three things and
I do mean Journal meaning you write it
down in the morning and you review it at
night
so you're that's why it says journal and
review so you write in the morning and
review it all at night and so here's
what the G3 is the first thing you know
is your gratitude
and that is just what are you grateful
for why does that make you feel good why
are you thankful for it and just write
it down in your Journal just a whole
like you should have a gratitude Journal
already but when you're disappointed or
having setbacks I want you to do the
Gratitude in the morning a lot of
gratitude Journal stuff is at the night
I want you to move it right at the
morning like just you got to prime your
morning for some goodness so right off
the bat you got to do that okay so
gratitude second major thing I want you
to focus on is your goals
we're the specific daily and weekly
goals you're working on you've got to
get really narrow focused right when
you're disappointed or sad or setback uh
you know the idea of creating a vision
board and seeing out 10 years from now
that's too much what you need to do is
get really close and near term this day
is goals this week's goals because you
can check those suckers off and get a
little progress in you'll feel
differently as we talk about so goals is
important and the third G is goodness
and the goodness is noticing what is
Good from the previous day
so when you start the day you're like
okay what am I grateful for in general
for Life what are my goals specifically
daily and weekly in each of these
different areas of my life you might
have goals in your career and your
health and your finances and your
relationships and then the goodness is
what actually good did happen yesterday
and that will just get you in a place
where you're like oh this day is going
to be good too it's making you more
mindful to all the good things and the
reason I do that one last and the
difference between gratitude gratitude
is General things you're grateful for
the goodness thing is to think about
what good happened yesterday and the
reason we do that because in
Neuroscience we know that thinking about
the goodness from yesterday is
triggering your hippocampus to kind of
turn on and fire up and if we get more
memory activation off the bat in the
morning we actually have more creativity
in the day too it's weird sparking
memory is good for creativity creativity
is very good for coping and so that's
why I'm trying to get you to reflect a
little bit on something that happened
yesterday just to Think Through find
that mindful moment and it's also
teaching you to be more mindful at
through of the moments each day not just
grateful in general but actually being
mindful for the good moments each day so
I want you to do that journal every
morning and then every night I want you
you to look back at it
and think about it and maybe repeat it
if you want to I just want you to review
the day and review those things what was
I grateful for oh yeah that's right
because maybe at the end of the day the
truth is you haven't moved a lot forward
maybe you know your your spouse or
yourself you're still sick or maybe
there's still conflict or maybe the
business is still because I'm not going
to be pollyanish and say everything
changes in one day and everything's
great just because you did your
gratitude Journal you might get in a day
it still sucks so reviewing it is going
to put you back in that positive mindset
that's going to help you then take the
next day as well before you hire a team
I really encourage you to either hire
one person and the two of you Outsource
a lot of the tasks so you learn what
that looks like because if you have an
outsourced tasks before you're going to
be a pretty crappy manager or leader
right if you just go I'm going to hire a
bunch of people and you get them on
board but you've never actually manage
task assignment and task completion
it gets really hard so what I tell most
people if you're just starting which I
know many of you were in your brands or
businesses or many of your solopreneurs
and you asked me about this and he said
Brandon what if I'm just hiring my first
two people what would you do I see my
first two people I might first
understand your skill sets I might hire
somebody to be your virtual assistant or
somebody to plug one specific skill set
hole that you just don't have
but then the two of you before you hire
number three four five and six I
actually want the two of you or yourself
to Outsource first go to like upwork go
to Fiverr go to something where you can
put out tasks as projects to people and
manage that
see how that feels see if you like that
see if you find yourself going I don't
really like working with other people
some of you should never work with
another human being you're just you're
horrible you just should you should just
know that about yourself and accept that
about yourself step into that truth if
you don't want to lead or be around
people you know what you'll find that
out pretty soon as you start Outsourcing
I really encourage you in other words
I'm sort of imploring you
take baby steps
baby steps into hiring just baby steps
it it's like when you go to college and
business school they're just like well
start with hiring your team and defining
your culture and having a mission
statement and values and I'm like that's
even fast for most people the worst
thing someone can do is go hire five
people and not even know if they know
what their business is what their skills
should be or if they like assigning
delegating and following up on tasks
so first Outsource and in general most
of the repetitive or simple tasks that
you have in your business you should
look for ways to Outsource that first
before you hire internally why it's just
straight up basics of math it will
always be cheaper to Outsource to
contractors and Outsource to people who
you have the ability to hire and fire
immediately because their work for hire
versus it's somebody who's on your
payroll who who's a team member who you
have to give you know three warnings to
before you let them go
and especially if you're just starting
and you don't really know what the
Rhythm there is going to be for them to
work with you Outsourcing is great it
helps you find your Tempo it helps you
find what you really do as a business
to Outsource so I'd love for you to just
think about and you haven't done this
and you own your business or you lead a
team
to sit down and go okay what are all the
repetitive tasks that happen in my
business let me review where my week
went good and bad and let me decouple my
emotions from that so I can enter Monday
with freedom because when I am in a
space of freedom I make much better
decisions than when I am in the space of
lack when I am in the space of
self-hatred when I'm in the space of
carrying all this stuff unprocessed I
mean have we learned anything from
personal development other than hey you
got to process the stuff that went that
happened in your life and understand how
you identify with that and what you're
going to do next you got to process it
man and most people because they're not
processing their immediate snap
judgments of self oh I screwed up
imagine if we could just loop back your
last couple months
and every single week just think about
everyone think about how much you
screwed up the last couple months I
don't know about you but mine's like a
like like my hands would have to like I
can't I don't have enough hands like to
count the number of screw-ups in the
last couple months I can't it's like
it's so infinite number of screw-ups but
imagine if every time I screw up I'm
like oh you're screw up ugh you're dumb
Brendan and my self-talk in that moment
was snap judgment which most people it
is snap judging self doc dummy oh I know
this stupid Brennan oh
imagine if we take a loop of that for
the last six months uninterrupted
unpaused unedited and we took out all
the situations of life we removed all
context and it just sounded like screw
up you suck you suck you suck why'd you
do that oh my God dummy dummy dummy
stupid stupid stupid stupid stupid and
we didn't
de-hook that
we didn't decouple that
that's what most people's realities are
and because that's always running
unconsciously because they're not
deliberate about processing
they're not living a courageous life now
because every time they think a
courageous thought that overwhelming
chorus of noise
filters and swamps and smashes that that
Whisper of a dream that is bold is
beaten to death by the rap base
of The Horde talk that we have with each
other it's like in the back right
and so that noise
needs to be
synthesized and edited down
on a simple Sunday
you just sit there on your Sunday and
you go
all right man
had a lot of noise this last week
a lot of things didn't go the way I did
but you know what let me think about
them how could I have met those
situations as my highest self or more
courageous self what could I have done
okay good good Brandon you're learning
good job Brennan you're learning oh yeah
you could have been better then yeah
good for you having the intention to be
better good for you to learn Brendan
good for you to set higher intentions
Brendan good job being on purpose good
job Brennan trying to improve your life
okay good job you really you got a new
way to look at that Brandon good job
now just
Let It Go man
just take that emotion and let that
emotion float away for a little bit
don't let that emotion from that mess up
mess up my Monday
it's Sunday
I gotta let that go
I forgive myself in that situation
because I've learned I forgive the other
people in the situation because even if
they didn't learn I learned and they
gave me a lesson
I let go of that situation because that
situation is not in this moment as I'm
sitting here with my green tea and my
journal reflecting on last week in this
moment I got a journal I got a green tea
it's just me and the green tea so you
see we've got this opportunity to make a
space
every week in which we debrief the week
and decouple ourselves unhitch the
trailer of weight
and let it fall back down the hill if
I'm having a some dark days and sad
times I'm like I gotta get progress so
what I'll do is I'll identify my five
major moves if you read this book
hyperomis habits you know about five
major moves so identify my five major
moves and I'm like I'll swiftly move
towards one because momentum can shift
mindset and so if I'm in a dark
disappointment down momentum like
achieve some goals but here's what's
important notice I said the five major
moves that's what I mean with progress
because what a lot of people mistakenly
do is they just start doing lots of
tasks and activities that aren't
correlated in any way to the meaningful
Pursuits of life
so here's what happened
I'm bummed I'm down so I'm doing a bunch
of work
next day they still feel bummed and down
because what was their work it was a
bunch of activities that actually didn't
matter that didn't give them any meaning
so if you're down
the most important work you need to be
doing is the ones that you do feel
connection
enthusiasm meaning fulfillment
satisfaction from those ones that do
intrinsically bring you Joy those are
the ones that I want you to progress
towards matter of fact I really want you
when you're feeling down to supporting
major setbacks dark days what I really
desperately want you to do is stop
multitasking and doing all the little
like busy work things that don't matter
like like put off like if if it's
Wednesday and you know you got a stack
of bills and they're not due
for another 30 days
don't pay the bills that day because
that's not fun and you're you got plenty
of time to do it later when you feel
like when you get over this piece that's
Funk like just say okay write the date
on those bills pay them on but don't do
it today because that's busy work
instead today find an activity that you
find to be creative compelling engaging
fulfilling and do that progress towards
the things that have meaning that's huge
when you're down
but most people don't do that because
what's comforting just like eating
comfort food is doing low hanging fruit
activity I'll pay the bills and answer a
bunch of emails you know but those small
little tasks
those don't give you enough bang for the
buck to really move through it and
there's a big misconception about that
in the culture including the science
that often says oh no no just you know
if people can complete small steps small
tasks they'll feel better and it's like
well yeah I mean we all have this reward
system in our brain and a little
dopamine will fall out but do we do we
want a little drip drip of dopamine or
we want the floodgates to come open and
feel alive so I want you to do the
activities that are more meaningful not
just like tasks you know it's really
important you've got to start creating
meaningful moments in your life
what do I mean by that well listen you
and I both don't I mean how many times
you get caught up in the day you get
caught up in the news you're you know
swiping and looking and looking and
consuming you get caught up in your
to-do list you get caught up in all the
emails you get caught up in all the work
and all of a sudden the whole day went
by and you didn't feel it
and I'm here to tell you something
really remarkable that I've learned this
last year uh you know last year was my
first year where I as a high performance
coach I was coaching two billionaires
and I'd never done that before I mean I
mean many you guys know and you've been
with me on my journey you know for what
uh two decades I've been in personal
development and in this last decade it's
kind of where I made my mark you know I
published six books uh we grew our
audience to you know whatever five
million on Facebook and you know 800 000
or whatever is on Instagram now 800 000
on YouTube uh best-selling books
traveling you've seen us fill the rooms
and all the events that I do but this
last year was like a whole other level
for me it was so hard so challenging we
we moved Denise and I and I also started
taking on these caliber of clients I
mean holy cow I didn't know I didn't
know if I could handle it I mean I'm not
a billionaire I got no problem telling
anybody that I'm not out there trying to
pretend I you know pretend uh you can't
fake it with billionaires they know
and so when I was coaching them I kind
of struggled for a while to
figure out what they were unhappy about
I hope that doesn't sound flippant but I
was like wow they got so much going for
what what's up why why aren't you
happier if you have everything right
like the material things most people are
seeking why aren't you happier and I'll
ask you guys that same thing why do you
feel like you're not happier like what's
going on
I mean most people consumer watching
this I mean you're doing okay
I mean you might be unhappy here and
there you you might struggle with like
especially I mean a tremendous amount of
our audience and in personal development
is Strivers they're Achievers they're
working hard they're often the leaders
in their community and everybody goes
wow even they're already impressed with
you they're already happy that you're
chasing your dream they're already like
kind of like you're living your own
you're living life on your own terms a
little bit and so are these major people
I was coaching I couldn't figure out
what's going on with them and then I
finally I tripped on maybe it was the
last year the end of I think was the end
of the prior year
I got it
here they were doing amazing things guys
every single day they were living the
dream they had finances they they had
impact they you know people were
impressed with them they uh you know had
love often in their life they were
married or had good kids or whatever
but they still weren't happy and they
still did not feel connected
and here is what I discovered
they did not feel
the day
say it again they didn't feel
the day they went through the day some
of them very high achieving through the
day accomplishing things on their
purpose making a difference a role model
earning doing the whole thing and yet
when they laid their head on the pillow
at night they hadn't felt
the day
think about that for a moment think
about how many days you go to bed and
you didn't really feel
the moments of the day
and this is why too many days unfelt
leads to a disconnect with purpose
too many days unfelt leads to a
disconnect with purpose does that make
sense
and so what we what do we have to do we
have to create the habits the routines
the patterns where we learn to create
and feel meaningful moments it's I talk
about this in my book the motivation
Manifesto or you guys hear me talk about
it on the Brendan show a lot my podcast
where you you have to take
these moments in time and do what I call
Slow Time
it's like yes you're gonna kiss your
honey on the way out the door to work
but you know what when you plant that
kiss plant that kiss baby I like make it
a moment feel that moment you know when
you hug the kids and they run off to
school like really give a real hug don't
like pasta and move on to the next thing
we're always moving on to the next thing
and not feeling this moment
we're not present in the moment because
we're not thinking about let me create
something meaningful here let me feel
something here because we're absent of
presence
and the sense of meaning in the moment
we are disconnected from purpose the
spark of motivation which is how I
anchor into being motivated each day is
ambition
all motivation begins with a desire or
hunger and ambition for more whether
that's more depth or more connection or
more contribution or more abundance or
more wealth or more love like we just
want more of something and that says I
want to go get that like we see a
fancier car it's better than our car I
want to go get that we see like a deeper
love of relationship between two people
I said I want that in my own life
sometimes it's a visual cue something we
see makes us want something right
they're not too far from here there's a
beach that I strolled on vacation
I don't know a couple years ago and I
said I want to live here
and it was a motivation it was a cue I
saw something desired it wanted it went
after it like so sometimes it's a visual
it's a cue out in the world that says I
want more of that thing if you will
realign to the core truth of who you are
stop faking it stop forcing it reconnect
with what your authentic passions and
desires are reconnect to your soul
listen to The Whispers of your heart
realign to uh the authentic style of
living that you know is true for you not
doing it for other people
make sure you fulfill those aspirations
you're being aspirations be the best of
who you are do things you're proud of
relate with other people in the ways
that you intend to create things that
you're proud of
make sure that you adopt that role model
mindset when you're adopting the role
model mindset you're activating your
full potential because you want other
people to see that you want to do things
of integrity and value in the world
because you want other people to role
model that themselves you're creating
the world that you want to be in by
living that you're activating your
potential you're being a role model that
will connect you with purpose you don't
have to seek it it will connect you when
you are in potential
when you are in potential and you are
serving by being a role model and being
of service to other people not for
yourself but to be of service to other
people
you are connected to purpose you must
start training your mind now
to deal with stress
many of you that means it is finally
time to start learning meditation
it's like you've been thinking about it
you kind of meditate once in a while and
you've thought about it or you did that
one Retreat one time I'm like make it a
daily part of your life
to Center yourself
every single day
for some of you centering yourself that
just means closing your eyes thinking
about who you want to be think about
what's important
just calming your mind down other people
centering is like like that can be just
like if you're super stressed lay down
take a quick nap for some of you that
can mean like the important self-talk
some of you that means meditation like
for me if I don't Center myself every
day twice a day actively the next day I
know I'm gonna get short with somebody
I'm gonna let anxiousness get to me I'll
get my nerves I'll get frustrated I'll
bow out I'll quit it's so clear it's
like super obvious to me
that the days that I don't Center
end up in tomorrow's
that are chaotic
and so I just gotta make sure I take
that time every day that might mean you
go take a 45 minute walk many of you
guys know every single day I walk
outside every day rain water snow sleet
I don't care I will walk 30 to 45
minutes outside every day I don't miss
because that just being out in nature
and breathing and feeling the wind on my
face and the sun just calms me down gets
me grounded back into the Earth and in
nature it's like oh okay
every day
so for what 20 plus years I meditate at
least once a day
I think for the last
maybe 11 years of meditate meditated
twice per day sometimes it's only five
minutes both sessions sometimes it's 10
minutes both sessions and when I don't
get that I might I might take like a 30
minute nap in the afternoon at some
point I'll sneak away even when I used
to have a corporate job and work for
somebody else I'd go close the door in
one of the rooms run the meeting
conference rooms I close my eyes for 20
minutes I meditate take a nap lay on the
floor do whatever I have to do to
re-center my mind first we're gonna look
for in a passion for what we do which I
know is very esoteric but you need to
know it right for our company for our
industry we look for people who are
passionate about personal development
professional development and growth
personal change self-help people who
love personal growth and challenge we
want people who have a passion for that
so we identify the passion related to
our company you have to do that too and
you have to be able to articulate it
because you're going to look for it in
interviews then for us because we're
still a startup we're you know under 40
some people right our goal is we look
for the ability or the history
to deal with unknowns
and to get stuff done
meaning people were adaptable flexible
who can come in and kind of figure
things out and get things done they have
an experience of either starting new
things or being on projects where it was
not super well defined the company they
worked for or the teams they worked with
were fairly flat and self-managed just
people who can kind of come in and
figure things out and get things done
third we're looking for people who have
ownership to any failures or struggles
one of my favorite questions to ask
people when I'm interviewing one-on-one
is a question like
um you know tell me about a time when
you're working on a project that you
really loved and it completely fell
apart
and a project that was really important
and it didn't turn out well how did you
handle it tell me about that and if they
describe that and all they do is talk
about how everybody else screwed up and
they were the Savior and uh then they're
probably not the right person
I look for people go you know what this
was a project we're working on it didn't
go so well and I want them to be able to
see like
I'm bummed that didn't turn out if
someone can describe a train wreck with
no emotion to it don't hire them so if
you ask somebody tell me about a time
that you did a project and it sucked and
they're like
and they have no emotion they're called
a sociopath don't hire those they don't
do good in culture okay you want to make
sure that someone has feeling and
emotion to something that failed in the
past that that's going to have passion
for what you're doing I always tell
people one of the number one things I
love to hire for which is weird with my
new team here but I love to hire for
this single quality guilt
I love to hire for Guilt what I mean is
I love to hire people that I know if
they do a bad job they'll feel bad about
it think about it you wake up you grab
your phone you're like
you know and all of a sudden you don't
have any motivation instead you look
through all this stuff and all it did is
make you feel like you're not enough or
distracted you or it upsets you or
created you know anger anxiousness you
got to be careful how you're using cues
to start your day
I use cues to start my day motivated
and those cues to start my day motivated
are things like I literally wake up and
I'll wake up and I'll think of things
that I'm grateful for and that I want to
give in life
I'll wake up and I'll think about
someone I want to do something nice for
or surprise today I'll think of
something I can be excited about today
oh as soon as possible in the morning
fin revisit my ambitions list my goals
list I'll look at them I'll not wander
through the day looking at social media
and then oh I guess it's time to work
and look at my goals it's like my goals
I mean in the first few minutes of the
day I'm revisiting them and what I'm
doing is when I'm looking at my goals or
my agenda or my schedule I'm looking at
it I'm thinking okay why do I want this
What would life be like like this how
could I go get it what should I do today
to make that happen and that motivates
me that's my list of goals my list of
Ambitions the things that can excite me
in other words it's very intrinsic goals
it's intrinsic rewards that I'm after
I'm like if I go do that I will feel
better if I could have this I'd be
happier right it's not that I can't be
happy with now but I want to pull like
if I can have that future pull
that's going to motivate me to go do
stuff right I have to literally generate
that in my mind and so when I have that
connection in the morning then my
takeaway for you is connect with your
Ambitions every morning very first thing
in the morning somehow a part of your
morning routine connect with your
Ambitions look at them why do you want
them what would you get from that how
would you feel from that what would that
generate why would that be more
meaningful really connect with that
ambition every single morning and you'll
start to notice you feel better is there
somewhere can you show me on a wall
visually in your house not on your
computer not in your little phone you
know not on this one little note that
you tuck away and you hide from
everybody else so they don't see what
you're working on
no show me a wall
with your battle plan
see so many people don't break through
and they don't break through because
what's end up happening for them is so
often they're in this place where you
know unfortunately the the truth is the
truth is they didn't have a plan
and they won't talk about it and they
won't say anything to anybody and yet if
you get down to it you start coaching
you start working with them you find out
they didn't have a plan
they did not have a plan and so I think
it's so important that you realize the
value
of having your battle plan right so a
battle board what's a battle board if I
show to your house you would have a wall
somewhere maybe it's a you know maybe
you wrote it on a regular eight and a
half by eleven or if you saw it in my
room it's like I went to I literally got
like butcher paper
and I take you know some blue tape
and I scrap this thing
no I accept this thing on this butcher
tape across the wall and what is on that
wall there's 12 boxes on that wall
ladies and gentlemen what's on that
Battle Board 12 boxes what's each box
yep a month each box represents one
month and within that box what do I have
written down the goals that have to
happen that month the metrics that have
to happen that month the steps I'm going
to take that month the Key activities of
that month right there on the Battle
Board y'all got it
So and I've seen a lot of these from
clients before I'll walk in and there's
their Battle Board you know and then
they might have a fancy one made out of
burlap and tax and beautiful Instagram
ready Battle Board and and here's what
they got they got their mission
statement of the cross the top
and then they've got on there a reminder
of the three words of who they want to
be as a person you know enthusiastic
bold present
oh I like that then they've got the 12
boxes oh look in July here's the numbers
they're trying to hit here's what
they're trying to do in August here's
what they're trying to do in September
and on that Battle Board it might be the
most simple things it might be in
September event coming up okay what are
they doing before the event here's the
five steps okay October what are they
doing they're taking the vacation here's
what's going on
but visually
representing your battle plan that's on
a wall that you see all the time
is so important the very first move you
must do when you feel that coming on
when you're like getting whacked around
and into chaos the very first thing I
want you to always remember to do is
Center in on your breath
I want you soon you feel like Angry
start taking deep breaths from the belly
and I want you to count those breaths 20
times
just just start like immediately start
counting your breathing if someone's
hollering and screaming before you
holler and scream back and react breathe
the best way to Center the mind of the
body is through deep breathing there's
literally thousands of years of research
behind this in terms of both the the the
the the more anecdotal to what we now
know in Neuroscience that deep breathing
can deeply calm the mind and help you
make better decisions so
just breathe just breathe perspective
you get
from time away from something
or from other angles into something
and so the most important thing that I
can encourage you to do just like I ask
you to socialize sadness is to share how
you're viewing the problems
that you're having in your life or the
challenges and what I mean by that is
literally share how you're thinking
about it so if
you're struggling with something with
your team your business then go to your
team and say hey um can I just walk you
through how I'm thinking about this and
seeing this
uh perspective is not trying to solve
anything right this doesn't say problem
solving it says perspective it means you
share specifically with other people how
you are thinking about something and ask
how would they would think about it
follow me so it's like you know I I'm
I'm dealing with this loss in the
business right now and uh it's really
bumming me out I don't know really how
to think can I just share you how I'm
thinking about it and you need either a
coach who can hear that a a comrade a
collaborator a colleague someone who you
know like and Trust who you can just
share how you're thinking through more
often because most disappointments
happen because we get myopic
meaning we narrow our Focus
solely to the problem
and in not describing how we're viewing
it we can't broaden it
and so no matter what we have found in
almost all social psychology research in
almost everything that I know to be true
having coach High performers for so long
is that if we can get you sharing how
you're thinking about things and feeling
about things with others and not trying
to problem solve but just asking how
they would look at it it actually makes
you look at a different way like here's
what's been going on here's how I'm
looking at it how would you look at it
and they might go oh
well I look at that that's like really
great for you
you go what and like well it gives you
time now to to kind of restart
you know it's like the when Steve Jobs
came back to Apple
he had a very different perspective
going back to Apple than he had when he
was already running it before but got
fired
and that perspective allowed him to do
better he had to go to another
organization and start another company
and have a whole new set of team members
to help them look at things differently
that allowed him when he came back to
the same problem if you will the same
opportunity if you will Apple he saw it
in a completely different way because
he'd been with a different group of
people
considering a different problem and he
learned a new ways to think and that's
what we always have to do keep expanding
your ways of thinking about things make
purpose felt by feeling the date
create those meaningful moments again
Kratom just take a little moment slow
down time when you're with your loved
ones slow down time when you're doing
your art one way to do that is stop
being distracted and trying to multitask
and do 50 things be in the moment when
you're doing personal development be in
personal development man be there with
your Journal when you're when you're
when you're you know at dinner with your
loved one when you're on date night be
there when you're with the kids playing
be there when you're with your team
leading be there that idea of being
fully present again reconnects you to
purpose and suddenly it's not about what
did you achieve externally you just feel
purposeful you feel a life of purpose
because you are doing things that are
meaningful that are serving aspirations
that are serving as a role model that
are being of service to other people and
all of a sudden you're just like I'm
there I feel purposeful even if it
doesn't matter how much you have in the
bank or what the car is like or what the
house is like those things are wonderful
but those things are also often a result
of realigning to your truth
I say it all the time
sometimes the universe or God or luck or
whatever the Stars whatever you want to
call it doesn't give you what you want
because based on all of your
distractions and lack of discipline and
authenticity
it's simply unsure what you're asking
for
if you are asking to feel more purpose
you must realign your life to a life
that feels purposeful it's very easy for
me to be really effective in the
mornings and then that afternoon two
three o'clock and I can just be like
man
I want to go outside take a walk
come back turn on some Netflix eat some
carbs you know that can be my afternoon
if I'm not careful so here's what I do I
have a checkpoint in the mid-afternoon
to recognize reward appreciate anything
that I have done today anything that I
have done today and that midpoint
checkpoint for me on my phone I just
have an alarm mine tends to go off
around 2 30 or 3 o'clock in the
afternoon it just flashes to me and it
says what's been great today what's been
great today
and so that'll kill me all right it's
time to visit what's been great today so
I'll just think about something I've
done it could be like I answered 10
emails today that I have been avoiding
good job it could be as simple as I made
that one call I said I was gonna call
did it I shot that content created that
thing whatever some type of like listen
motivation is often driven by
recognition
so recognize what you have done so far
in the day
early afternoon
then what I do in order to keep myself
motivated even more because I've set my
mind I want to be a person who's
Excellence driven
what I will do is I say okay
here's what's great so far and then I
asked a system a question
how do I complete this day with
excellence
A Simple Touch point in the afternoon
how do I complete this day
with Excellence so I will look at the
rest of the day whether that's two hours
more four hours more five hours more six
hours more whatever it's going to be for
me and I go okay how do I think through
the rest of this day with real
excellence and when I can connect with
that I'm telling you
it's just it's just so part of me and it
really makes me want to serve so please
think about having a mid-afternoon
connection point to keep yourself
motivated you'll feel a whole different
quality of life come in I promise it's
it's a different experience for people
because most people they're just running
and gunning through the day they don't
realize uh or understand or accept how
challenging it is to lose motivation and
so they've gone many people they've gone
weeks without being motivated they're
going through the motions
but there's no energy there's no
emotional pull towards something better
and because they're lacking that
emotional pull what ends up happening
they dog it they don't contribute as
much did you look at your goals every
day this year
every day did you look at your goals
every day this year it's such a simple
question
every day I don't mean once in a while
every day
and if you didn't my invitation to you
is to consider the fact that maybe
the amount of time that you're spending
with your goals is not sufficient enough
to motivate you
maybe the amount of time you're spending
with your goals is not sufficient enough
to keep you focused
maybe the amount of time you're spending
with your goals is not sufficient enough
to activate that unconscious brain that
says huh
I know how to achieve that
maybe it's the reason you're not coming
up with more ideas in the shower in the
morning because you're not cueing your
brain with enough representation or
enough sorry repetition of looking at
your specific goals because when you
look at your specific goals over and
over and over and over again day after
day after day after day it literally
helps rewire your brain and it helps
program your brain to say oh let me pay
attention to ideas thoughts and feelings
I have consciously and unconsciously
that might be able to manifest these
goals
this is why having a visual
representation of what you are after and
looking at it every day is so critical
to all of personal development training
of all time but why is it that so many
people still don't do it
they just get caught up more people look
at other people's Instagram every day
than they do their own goals
and we wonder why so many people are
struggling to achieve things faster when
we lack motivation it is a slippery
slope to suffering
so please recognize that you must
cultivate more motivation
what else can you do well I'll tell you
it's like ambition attention to those
Ambitions effort towards those things I
think all of that is is really really
really clear but I also really believe
that a lot of emotion motivation is
simply lost because of fatigue
so let's say you're doing all those
things but you're wiped out you're tired
like a lot of motivation really rests on
how you feel physically if you feel
lethargic you feel tired you have the
flu it's like it's harder to be more
motivated you can still do it by doing
what I'm talking about re-cue yourself
reconnect with those things but
health-wise it's really critical for you
to say okay if I want to be motivated
long term I need to feel greater levels
of mobility and energy in my body so if
you ever hung around me I'm constantly
bouncing and moving and breathing if
you've been with me at HPA you see some
of these practices this breath work that
I do that I'm activating and opening up
my body so that my body says let's go
versus right so my body's not like oh I
ate this terrible thing I said my body
says I feel refueled I feel ready to go
let's go focus on doing activities that
draw your passion
don't focus on the success the outcome
the final goal the Final Destination
a lot of our discouragement comes
because we're trying to make that
specific thing happen and we have a way
in which we think it has to happen and
let me tell you what I know a lot of
people who they actually did that they
they work diligently for years and years
and years to manifest their dream and
now they've you know they've achieved
the outward appearance of that success
they've got the bigger house the bigger
cars they've got the you know the Yachts
the boats the fancy vacations you know
abundance in every single way and
they're unhappy
because along the way they were focusing
on those external things
versus the activities that bring them
Joy passion and fulfillment
and what happens is you want to
compromise on the activities that are
actually part of the dream so that you
can have the dream right it's that
person who works a job that sucks for 20
years to finally get paid something to
finally quit that job to do the thing
they really wanted to do so for 20 years
they did things that they weren't even
passionate about fooling themselves like
well I just need to save and save and
save and finally one day be able to go
do my dream and it doesn't really like
make any sense don't give up 20 30 years
of your life doing something hoping to
earn the right to do the thing you want
to do start doing the activities you
enjoy and make you feel challenged or
creative or satisfied or fulfilled or on
fire now
I think that's what's so important
everyone thinks the dream lives in a
destination
and I always say no no the dream lives
in the activities that you do today
are you doing today what you would do if
you had the outcomes you seek because I
know a lot of wealthy people who are
miserable in their lives they achieved
outward experience but they were
miserable because they're not doing the
activities in the day that actually
bring them joy and fulfillment
so if you need patience throughout this
journey the patience will come from
connecting with the activity every day
like don't wait to have the dream do the
dream
And if every day you touch that like
experience do you you're doing that
dream every day even just a little piece
of it then you don't get so discouraged
you know when you get discouraged when
you're just not doing it
but there's almost no dream that you
could have that you can't be doing
something and touching that every single
day some activity every single day that
is actually part of the dream you know I
have a friend whose dream was to become
a world-class chef
and so they were going you know they
were like saving all this money to go to
culinary school and they were having
like terrible jobs and they were just
like I'm gonna be a chef one day I'm
gonna be Chef one day I'm gonna be Chef
one day and I hung out with this person
long enough to go hey man I know your
dream has become a chef but you don't
even cook right now and like no no I'm
working to save to go to culinary school
so one day I can be a chef I'm like no
no you can be a chef right now cook
dinner tonight in an artistic fun way
touch the dream now we look for people
who have a passion to take initiative
add new value we look for people who
have a spirit of collaboration you know
what the spirit of collaboration always
ends up being it's two things number one
Spirit of collaboration is enthusiasm do
they have enthusiasm for the job for the
gig for what they're doing does that
enthusiasm show through like I always
hire for enthusiasm but then two
collaboration requires openness
it requires openness to new ideas to new
people
and that openness when people have
openness they have a different way of
receiving and giving feedback
they're more in the learning mode and so
we're looking for that you need a 30 45
minute interview tops like interviews
should be quick because you should know
what you're asking for by the time they
get in the door you're either you your
HR company or the Staffing Company
you're working with they should have
already done the preliminary work to see
like when they come in the door they're
already qualified like at a technical
level or an interest level like they
should already or project management
level or uh or you know you see their
library of work before like it should be
obvious that they could do the job or
they have interest in the job so by the
time they get in the room you're not
really qualifying their intelligence or
their skill sets or their personalities
because frankly you could assess all
that before they get in by looking at
their resume by looking at their library
of work in the past uh by giving
personality assessments in advance if
you want to do that kind of thing some
of our companies we give personality
assessment in advance some of them
aren't we don't
so it's up to you so you have to Imagine
by the time they get in the room the
whole point by the time they're in the
room is that's a few questions
to really gauge them on the things that
are most important to you so I managed
my sleep my diet my health in ways that
support my mental Clarity and energy
and I know that like the sounds
sometimes people think motivation is
just a mental game I'm like yes but your
mind and your body are connected your
body is lethargic so is your mind right
that brain Body Connection is real y'all
and I know you know that you've been
sick you've been tired there's other
times when you've been out of shape you
feel terrible so I'm here to encourage
you as I always do if every single month
in high performance I have to cheer you
on to get in Better Health to prioritize
your health to sleep good to eat well to
move if I have to do that every single
month I will do that I will be a
champion I will cheer you on I want you
in excellent Health this year so please
hear me cheer that on every single month
because I just know I get you in Better
Health I get you in better mental health
we'll get you in better mental health
it's easier to sustain that fire and
that drive patience is easier when you
are constantly learning mastery
and what I mean by this if you've heard
me teach a lot I'm often telling people
make sure you know the five critical
skills that you would need to develop to
become world class at whatever you want
to do
I mean to become really good at what
skills would you have to master
like for me I would have to master not
just writing but I would have to master
how to promote a book how to build my
brand how to run a business
how to communicate on video and stages I
had no idea how to do like any of that
and you can tell I still suck at some of
that right it's like it's not easy but
because on the way to become
best-selling author I was always
studying how to do all that stuff
learning
can make you feel more patient because
you like learning is giving you progress
learning is readying yourself for that
moment you get the big break
learning makes patients easier because
your mind feels more competent it's like
you know what I'm learning here
at least I'm getting some momentum maybe
you know the doors aren't opening maybe
the bank account isn't filling up but my
mind is getting sharper at this I'm
developing skill
and when you develop skill your mind
says Hey progress we're doing okay when
the mind says Hey progress we're doing
okay patience is so much easier it's
when you're sitting there you know the
people used to say throw in your thumbs
now they just say blame to do it
it's like when you're sitting there
playing video games all day it attached
from the dream not doing activities the
dream and you're not learning you really
fall into complete Detachment from
progress and now you just it's not even
a matter of patience you just flat out
give up
because the mind needs a sense of growth
and that growth has either come from
learning or doing questions like what
attracted to you what attracted you to
wanting to work with us
what what about our company or this role
made you passionate about it tell me
about a time that you set a difficult
goal and you hit it tell me about a time
that you want a project or had a goal
and it totally failed how did you handle
that that gets to the points I made
earlier who do you admire the most
and why
I love that question because you'll
start to see people's heart come out
in an interview could you admire why do
you admire them but also who do you want
to be a hero to or who do you want to
admire you
which is a really great question because
it gets people really thinking about how
they live their life and for whom and it
gets to a more personal level often in
interviews what do you think would make
you successful here
that kind of checks have they paid
attention to the company do they know
what they're applying to do they know
what your culture is like do they have
any have they done their homework let's
see uh have you seen our website or what
we do in the marketplace do you have any
advice that we could already be better
like where where could we improve what
we do what do you know about us what
could we do better give us some advice
to see if they're actually paying
attention what project would you
consider your most significant career
accomplishment I just like to say what
what's a project you've done that you're
really proud of that was really the most
important thing
and you hear and get to see their
passion and their enthusiasm and the
sense of fulfillment that they might
have we also like to say why would you
like to be part of this team
like what is it about this place these
types of questions they're not the
end-all be-all questions you could go
pick up any you know book on
interviewing at your local bookstore and
see and yes please go to your local
bookstore
um and see like hundreds and hundreds of
questions you have to know what are the
questions important to you
and that's it that's it and if you ask
the right questions and you get the
right Vibe then it's like okay because
by the time they come in the door they
can probably do the job now in the
interview it's all about those things of
can you see the passion feel the heart
feel the Fulfillment see that they're a
good person see that I have enthusiasm
about it see that they're ready and
they're hungry to do the work see that
they're confident we did you know we've
done interviews in the past with some of
our companies the persons we interviewed
they lack like they didn't really want
to be there or they didn't seem like
they would be good fit for a team they
were more of like the individual
contributor and they were smart but you
couldn't see that they would be like
willing to work with people and you're
not trying to hire all the same type of
person but you or same type of skill set
but you are as a leader and you should
write this down you're you're not trying
to hire the same person
not trying to say hire the same IQ or
personality but you are trying to hire
the same kind of heart
you're trying to hire somebody who has
enthusiasm for their day for their work
the kind of heart that wants to do
excellent work
the kind of heart that wants to get to
work the kind of heart that cares about
other people
so I was saying when you're building a
culture you're not building a culture
based on skill set you're building a
culture based on heart set
like are these people who care enough
about each other and have high
enthusiasm in their life and for the
role
and if you get that right you're going
to create some kind of magic and people
won't know the magic they won't know you
thought through all this but all of a
sudden they'll start seeing it right
right off the bat they're like oh
there's something special going on here
and it's because you hired for the heart
set not just the skill set intention
intention intention for me I train
myself on three words I want to be and
I'll remind myself I'll just remind
myself those three words remind myself
of those three words remind myself those
three words because it's easy for me to
reactive and be responsive instead I
want to be intentional
so I know those three words that really
defined you and repeat those like
oftentimes or I'm if you ever see me
around and I'm like this
all I'm doing is I'm kind of rocking I'm
breathing in and out deeply I'm getting
attentive to my body and my posture and
I'm repeating my three words just to
reconnect because I do that every day in
the moment of Crisis because moments of
Crisis it feels like everything's out of
control but what can I control breath
body awareness what I say to myself
breath body and errors what I say to
myself I do that over and over and over
again and it really helps me lock back
in I hope this supports some of you
because emotionally learning to be
centered emotionally will so support you
as you go to change your life what is
fun for you right I know that's so basic
but can you really think of I mean if I
ask you right now and be honest if I ask
it what are the top you know 10 most fun
times you've had in your life
do they come easily to you
see for most people it doesn't they're
like well that was that time that I went
on a roller coaster and I jumped out of
a plane or you know that time I was at a
wedding and I danced like the chicken
you know like they really struggle and
partially what happens for people is
they just go through life kind of
bumbling and crashing around and they
never have any real reflection
on what brought them joy happiness
engagement enthusiasm fun so what I do
is when I have a fun moment that and
then I I'm a big journaler as many of
you know I I'm always encouraging at the
end of your day Journal about things
that you're grateful for things that you
desire cool things or
um inspiring things you saw people say
or do you know just Journal about your
life about philosophy whatever it is but
I like to ride at night and I always try
to write also a component of what was
fun today
I reflect on what was fun so for me you
know I've got so many access points so
many references of what was fun in my
life it's just immediate that I know the
things that bring me great joy because
I've thought about them so do you have
your fun list things that bring you
great joy and great fun in your life and
you know what those should be
your to-do list
because here's what people do their
to-do lists every day are tasks not life
and that's why they're miserable they've
gotten lost into the minutia of what
must happen versus who they could be
that day and that's where their life
starts to derail and they lose that
charge it's so magical in life so what's
your fun list you know what are those
things that you could do that would
bring great joy and fun into your life
and do them more often and automatically
you're having more fun you have to teach
your mind to honor the struggle
you have to teach your mind every day
you're getting discouraged and instead
of saying well I guess I'll quit I suck
this is no good it's never going to
happen you have to take control of the
self-talk and honor the struggle like
literally tell your mind how to deal
with the process tell your mind no no
this process this hardship this struggle
it's part of conditioning me
to be ready for the dream to succeed
this part of the struggle that I hate
right now it's developing character it's
making me force it it's helping me
challenge it's making me grow in other
words anticipate the fire anticipate the
difficulty anticipate that it's gonna
suck anticipate in days that you just
don't like it you know I'm a high
performance coach so I'm blessed to work
with some of the most like literally
extraordinary people in the world and
some of my favorite clients in the past
have been working with us military and
you know it's like uh you know if you
ever heard like that Green Beret
conversation where they use this phrase
embrace the suck right Army Special
Forces will say like embrace the suck
like yeah this sucks but it makes us
awesome like let's dig in let's get
better let's skill up let's use this to
build our character our strengths our
skills our ability to win in the future
so all the things that suck right now
you're like oh my God I can't figure
this out it's gonna make you better
and I don't mean this just
philosophically let me give an example
at the very beginning of my writing
career I went completely broke I mean
totally broke totally bankrupt like
literally nothing wiped out clean
because I didn't know how to do it I
don't know I know how to write a book I
didn't know how to make money I didn't
know how to promote it just completely
wiped out a hundred percent
and I mean to the point where it's like
I couldn't even have credit cards so
they've gone into bankruptcy so they
took the credit cards I had no credit
nothing I had a debit card
and no money on it no and it was like
the worst time and I remember I'm going
through this and I'm like and I want to
be like a personal development guy I
want to be a life coach I want to be a
high performance coach one day I want to
inspire people and I can't afford a
burrito
I was like it was miserable but I was
like no this is going to teach you to be
frugal this is going to teach you to
manage cash
this is going to teach you to be
resourceful when everybody else has
fancy stuff you're going to outperform
them with stuff that isn't as great I'm
going to learn to be a resourceful human
and and prioritized being Innovative and
creative versus just having all this
stuff so I didn't have the fancy cameras
I I wrote on my I borrowed a
three-legged table from my mom from the
sewing room you know and I was just like
type on that I borrowed a laptop from
somebody to write my book I was just
like you know pinching every penny and
dime to afford rent and then when I
couldn't afford rent I had to move in
with my girlfriend and and you know I
had to ask friends for help and support
and it was so humbling
and notice I said humbling I didn't say
embarrassing I didn't say shameful I
didn't say sad I didn't say discourage
it was humbling it was like you know
what
people who get success they earn that
right now I'm earning it I'm putting in
the miles I'm dealing with the hardship
I'm going to honor this struggle as part
of the process keep a good attitude
Brandon because if you can survive this
you can build anything if you can rise
from this you can crush anything if you
deal with this emotional hardship now
you will have intellectual physical
spiritual emotional confidence for Life
a lot of people do achieve their dream
and guess what once you achieve your
dream guess what you don't have the
dream anymore
you got the goal you made it happen and
now if you show up and all is smooth
sailing and all is easy you know what a
lot of people do when they get success
the way they perceived it
they become tragic losses
they lose their Drive they lose their
motivation they aren't happy they're
like I worked so hard to get this I got
it and now I'm not fulfilled I'm not
satisfied life isn't greater
and guess what
a lot of those people
they complain the whole way and then
they got it and then when they got it
now that it was gone they were still a
complainer
and what are you without all the things
you're who you became as you strived
so what I'm here to tell you is along
this process along this struggle every
single day as it sucks as It's a Grind
it feels like a hustle as it feels like
you're like compromising everything and
it's just like oh my gosh honor this
process as a challenge
to you to become better human to develop
a better attitude to develop those
skills that are required like literally
experience it not as a journey to
achieve a dream experience it as an
opportunity to transform experience it
has opportunity to grow experience it as
an opportunity to test your metal and
ask what am I really made of how can I
deal with this and live a great life
right now not in 10 years when I hope to
make it how do I live a great life right
now because if you can't teach yourself
to live a great life right now when you
get financial abundance or you get the
dream or everything happens guess what
you're still stuck with you
and if you can't teach yourself to be
satisfied joy-filled emotionally
connected happy fulfilled now I'm here
to tell you after coaching literally the
most impressive people on the planet
people who are in covers of magazines
spiritual leaders presidents of the
United States having the experience of
working at the top echelons of every
organization at the top levels I can
tell you that there's a lot of people
who do get the dream and because they
weren't patient and they didn't develop
themselves along the way they hurried
into it they complained and crashed and
grinded into it they get there they
compromise their integrity they
compromise their health they never
taught themselves to be happy so they
got everything and they're still unhappy
and you're like you have everything how
are you unhappy it's because they never
taught themselves along the journey to
honor it and to use it as a training
ground for being the best selves every
day you know the old days like in the
80s and 90s they maybe you don't know
the 80s and 90s I don't know how old
they are but in the 80s 90s was very big
like
your values in words up on the walls all
around your office it was like Integrity
as if any company didn't have that as a
value but let's Integrity right or you'd
have another one over here of just like
love or like One Singular word you know
excellence and it was all over the place
and then there was a you know a big
poster with an eagle flying and
motivational quote from Les Brown or
something right you remember those like
that was really exciting times and
people loved all that stuff and and
that's all really good
but the issue with it is people don't
own it and live it because you're not
naming those things as things that we do
versus just cold words on a wall
and so you have to take all of your
values
and say what do we do here that makes us
unique
or good
and so like if you have values in your
mind that you want all your people to
have write all those values down as a
list
but then then write them
in a way that really defines what those
values are as things that you do
so for example uh when I share with my
team when I'm onboarding I share these
four things I say okay these are what
make us unique and special this is what
we do here as a culture so I say this is
what we do as a culture
versus just a word or a value Let me
Give an example like first one we
challenge ourselves
that embodies almost everything that is
important to me in this brand in this
business we challenge ourselves that's
something that we do right we challenge
ourselves and so when people turn
something in did you challenge yourself
on that
okay did you set a larger goal are you
going for a stretch goal are you trying
hard things did you challenge yourself
with what you're submitting here right
we want to always challenge ourselves to
develop deeper skills better abilities
better ways to contribute so we
challenge ourselves here we're going to
push and that also allows an
understanding like we're going to
challenge you because it's not challenge
yourself it's we challenge ourselves I'm
going to challenge you I'm going to
challenge you you're gonna challenge you
you're gonna challenge you you're gonna
challenge me
like setting the context the challenge
is part of this thing this we challenge
ourselves and that's the expectation
that for me embodies tons of principles
tons of philosophies that that's like
embodies hard work and Excellence that
um embodies the openness to feedback
that embodies the the willingness to
push beyond our Comforts those embodies
so many Concepts we challenge ourselves
now you need to make a list like this I
don't want you all to just go and you
know use mine I want you like what's
what's important to you what do we do
here the second one for us is we take
care of each other
that's a huge one I've been in you know
other companies where they say we treat
each other like family or
um you know we care for each other like
family whatever it is it's like we just
say we take care of each other and that
embodies that we're attentive
we're present with each other we know
each other's story we know what's going
on each other's lives we're here for you
if something sucks and you need a
shoulder to cry on or somebody to help
you with your work like we care about
each other is important we take care of
each other we take care of each other
like family we take care of each other
like we're all in this together
and that embodies openness that embodies
the willingness for feedback that
embodies the support that embodies
compassion and empathy and kindness I
don't put empathy on a freaking
billboard in the office I go we take
care of each other
and that embodies
that word does that make sense that's
what I'm saying to you like write it out
as we do these things like that's why
I'm saying it name your values as things
we do in relationships repair
is resilience
repair is resilience in a relationship
what do I mean by that well we think of
like perseverance in terms of resilience
I'm like no
in relationships it's repair the ability
to repair conflict after it happens to
say I'm sorry to apologize to accept
apologies to fix the situation or
understand like this happened we didn't
want that to happen let's try this next
time
and allowing the ego to fade out of that
to be able to say I'm sorry to be able
to say I was wrong to be able to say
you're right to be able to say you know
what we didn't want that together
without the hatred or the blame
is everything Denise said this morning
she says it's so important
to apologize
for the other to accept that apology
and for the two of you decide to move on
I love that right
it's like okay apologize the other
person's gonna go
I hear you apologizing I appreciate that
you're apologizing thank you for owning
that
what can we do better next time so we
don't run into that
and moving it from problem Focus to
solution Focus moving it from blame and
upset to the next thing that's so
important that's what I mean by repair
people have to learn how to repair
when they mess up together and you have
to anticipate we're all going to mess up
together right I mess up all the time
but I'm so personally in all areas of my
life but I'm the first to apologize oh I
didn't see that I didn't anticipate that
I'm sorry that happened oh I see where
you're coming from okay got it
understood and it's like that repair
like entry maybe it's because I'm a
people pleaser I want everyone to feel
good after an argument like right away
I'm not a steward I I can't remember
anything negative that happened last
week you can live the high performance
experience like literally now stop
thinking one day you'll be next level
world class best Rich happy fulfilled do
that now like live today as a wealthy
individual you feel wealth in your
mindset you feel wealth in your
abundance of life you feel wealth
because you're alive you feel wealth
because you're gifted this beautiful
breath you feel wealth and joy and
fulfillment now because the little
things the way the cat is the way the
dog is the way that beautiful person was
today who is kind to you the
opportunities you have in front of you
the internet that's free of learning
just like this there's so many things
along your journey to achieve your dream
that you can appreciate and notice and
be fulfilled from and I just want to
share with you that I got to have that
experience because many of you all along
my career
has cheered me on we bring the joy
we create a positive atmosphere a
positive Community we want that
enthusiasm and that joy and that
positivity because everybody has had the
opposite
and we have the opposite it sucks right
we've all worked for a a negative leader
we've all been in a negative environment
we've all been in that place where
you're just doing tasks and you're like
God this job sucks because there wasn't
a spirit that was imbued there and
you've all heard me say you know the
power plan doesn't have energy it
generates energy I don't believe we just
have joy spontaneously though it can
happen I think we're responsible for
bringing the joy in our life we have to
bring the joy into our workplace we
you're not always going to have tasks
that make you feel perfect and bright
and fulfilled
so you know what it's about how you
carry that load it's about your attitude
to the activities about your
understanding of how things all fit
together to make the big difference
these are Concepts that you share when
we say bring the joy it's like bring joy
into your work even if the work is
unloading the dishwasher bring joy into
the work even if the work is as simple
as like answering 50 emails bring joy
into the work even if you've made your
50th quote card for the week like it's
like you have to put the meaning into
your work
if you're going to be world class and
not hope for the meaning to come out of
every activity and task
right it's so important like Muhammad
Ali said he he hated every single
workout at some point he hated him but
he knew he had to do them to be
excellent
right it's easy not to
you know enjoy everything that you do so
you have to bring the joy to that thing
write down what is not fun for you and
quickly and efficiently and with honor
integrity to the utmost ability that you
can remove those things for your life if
you're doing things that just are not
fun for you you have to ask can I
delegate those are those truly necessary
are those creating an opportunity cost
in my life where I could be spending
more time doing things that are
fulfilling that are fun that do move the
needle of progress forward in life what
are you doing right now that you just
like gosh you hate it you you take no
meaning or Joy from that and if there is
something there you need to quit that
activity delegate that activity or
seriously question and plan for the
removal of that activity the utmost of
your ability sooner than later
if you're like I I have my dude my job
is no fun then either a you need to
bring more fun to that and transform the
energy there into fun or B you need to
plan your exit and if that sounds scary
make sure you watch my YouTube video
called why to quit it's about quitting
and the power of quitting because
sometimes until you quit what is wrong
in your life
a white space does not open for what is
right in your life to enter so sometimes
quitting something that is not fun is a
way to get closer to something that is
fun but first question yourself are you
bringing the fun it's the old zen master
tale that the only Zen that you find at
the top of the mountain is the Zen you
carry up with you
so being fun is what will make anything
fun I mean frankly I do a lot of things
and sometimes I'm like it's occasional
work I wish I didn't have to do it but
if I'm going to do it I'm going to bring
full presence and joy and fun to it
myself I just don't care to hold
anything above anybody it's like okay it
happened
and my thought is always
we didn't want that
we didn't want that because it's about
the relationship right we didn't want
that fight
we didn't want it they didn't want it to
go that bad no one wanted to get in the
screaming match and we always say oh no
you don't understand my spouse they want
to scream they want the argument
actually they don't
they just lack the education and the
perspective of how to do it differently
no one wants to be in anger and wants to
be in vitriol and wants to argue and
wants to be belittling and condescending
and awful they literally have never been
trained on a better way
they they're literally unaware or
ignorant of another way and it doesn't
mean they're a bad person or they're
stupid it means they haven't had that
training like it's a really struggle I
know for many of you in personal
development land right how many of us
like can't believe that people don't
understand basic personal development
stuff right and we get frustrated with
them
but a lot of people have never you got
to understand 98 of this world has never
had any training on mindfulness
well-being or relationship Improvement
zero training because in school all we
taught them was to memorize a bunch of
stuff from a bunch of old dead dudes
right it's like we we are not teaching
people how to do peopling
so you can't get mad that a 30 year old
person doesn't know how to resolve a
conflict
they never had any conflict management
training great leaders Envision a
compelling and different and vibrant
future than what is here they have an
alternative clear view of what the world
could be like tomorrow than it is today
right they have a shared purpose they
believe that they and others would be
compelled by interested inspired by and
want to work towards and that's a big
deal and you always read about it in
leadership right you have to have Vision
I mean it's biblical where there is no
vision people perish right we know the
power of having that Vision so you have
to sit down though and actually do it
the reason we say Envision versus just
have a vision is you have to sit it's a
practice of envisioning what should
tomorrow look like for my team what
should tomorrow be like for my business
for my organization what should tomorrow
be like for my life and not just
tomorrow a long-term mindset and view
the dream right that Magnificent
Obsession that that bold desire the
moonshot goals and purposes and missions
of Life the bigger picture that's
envisioning a different reality in the
future than we experience today and
that's what everybody gets excited about
in leadership where there's no vision
there's no leadership where there's no
vision people perish we always have to
continually sit down and envision where
are we where can we be going it's an
active process if you set a vision one
time and and you forget about it it's
not going to help you accomplish the
influence or the impact we want in your
lifetime or in those that you lead most
fun the fun that just really is magical
and so grateful often comes in a social
environment
friends
we've so lost the art of friendship in
our modern distracted digitized World
let me tell you what just at try to go
out to breakfast or lunch or dinner with
your friends at least at least once a
week if that sounds crazy to you then
you have lost your life into a world of
work and tasks and fake responsibilities
that are only pulling you away from life
you need to evaluate your life and say
why can't I get away with some friends
once a week for an hour or two for some
lunch dinner breakfast or brunch why am
I not going out to drinks with my
friends anymore you know and don't
pretend and say well it's because I'm I
got too old to go out and you know come
on
it doesn't mean you have to go out and
party like rock stars till five in the
morning it means brunch lunch dinner you
know a walk a stroll a workout with some
friends and enough time with them to
enjoy
sharing stories about Life Sharing
stories about what has been fun with
them friendship is the ultimate ultimate
Bedrock of fun it's it's the great
source and the Wellspring of fun there's
a quotable friendship is the Wellspring
of fun I mean it's just like one of
these things it's just like once you
have friendship and you have fun follows
you because it's your buddies but you
have to be around them and I know that's
hard look we're all busy but that's
where life is so do not do not neglect
it Denise and I were talking this
morning our morning morning walk and she
was talking about the power of
self-soothing
and it really resonated with me and I
was like oh yeah I think I'm good at
that how many days I feel super
frustrated or angry or or hurt or slow I
can't count them as days but those those
moments are there and I gotta calm
myself down
so again coming back to the release
meditation technique or coming back to
tapping or sell smooth self-soothing if
you guys were with me the other day I
taught the simple thing if you breathe
in
you breathe out
you breathe in
you read out and all you're doing is
you're putting pressure on the back of
your head near your cerebellum you're
pulling with pressure down over the neck
and onto the chest and I will just close
my eyes and I'll take the breath in and
breathe out and I'll do that 10 20 30 50
times I'll bounce in place 10 20 30 50
times I'll open up my body I'll tap I'll
do a lot of things because guess what I
know the sooner I end that anxiety and
that frustration the more productive
healthy and forward-looking I am
I don't want to be stuck there
so I have to self-soothe
remember if you aren't doing
self-soothing on an active basis you are
not even close to your real emotional
powers
what most people do is they just go
through the world reacting
go through the world feeling what their
biases feel going through the world
upset angry emotional rollercoaster 24 7
as if they don't have complete
and utter ability to change that and to
feel better over the long term it's not
easy
but if you're above the age of 20 years
old if you if you're above the age of 18
years old I hope you spend a lot of time
trying to learn to master your emotions
a lot of time trying to self-soothe when
you get angry or upset or frustrated if
you're dealing with stress the same way
today as you did three years ago welcome
to growth day God bless you thank you
for being here there is no excuse for
people not getting better at stress
every year of their life
but we just feel like oh stress just
happens to me well yeah emotions too
that is the definition of emotion it is
a physical and immediate impulsive
response
but an emotion is not a Feeling
a feeling is an ongoing series of
emotions that we hold on to
that becomes now as we hold on that
feeling and those thoughts that becomes
a mood
that mood becomes a habitual pattern
which establishes our overall affect our
attitude and ultimately our personality
and so if those moments of Stress and
Anxiety happen and you're not doing
something self-soothed where it's like
go take a bath go for a walk go to the
gym take a breath lay on the floor you
know go make your Wellness shake like
whatever you got to do
self-soothing is actually the ultimate
competitive advantage
when you're at work and two people in a
meeting and they're frustrated one
person loses their stuff because they
haven't trained themselves and the other
person can stay Cool Hand Luke and
steady the Peaceful Warrior
I'll put my money on a Peaceful Warrior
every day of the week
right when you see great executives
great leaders their ability to be even
healed even when it's hard is so
impressive if you haven't read the
autobiographies the speeches and the
writings of of a Nelson Mandela or a
Martin Luther King Jr I plead for you to
read those things even volatile people
like great leaders like a Winston
Churchill as an example who would find a
way to calm down yes sometimes I know
alcohol was there but also the ability
to change mindset to look at it in a
different angle or perspective their
ability to shift their mind from stress
to anxiety into flow or into peaceful
action
inspired me
inspired me so much I thought okay I
gotta learn how to do that okay if I
want to be resilient I gotta learn to
calm myself down
if I want to you know be stronger as a
leader I gotta calm myself down
research study and psychology found out
that both second person and third person
makes you more it makes yourself talk
more powerful so if you're into
affirmations you wouldn't just say I
want to do this I want to do this you
want to do what we call in the book
self-coaching where you would say you
know in my case yeah Brendan it's
important you do a good job here today
because you usually don't do interviews
and you really love Marie and you want
to do a good job for her and her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well and Brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky Brendan
that's a different level of going I'm
lucky I'm lucky right it is yes yes
another one another one I do every
morning the shower yeah assuming I take
a shower but every morning in the shower
because we all don't every day not every
morning no we do know it just doesn't
happen it does nothing it doesn't happen
I told you like 24 hours ago I was
staying at a bar in the woods at a
friend's house yes
um but the second thing I asked myself
in the in the shower every morning is
what might happen today that could trip
me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that Brendan
I say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate that you know what
something's going to go wrong during the
day absolutely and if I already know
everything like like this morning's was
okay you're in I think what we would I
think I'm yes North Manhattan where I'm
staying would you call it North you're
Uptown I'm uptown and you're coming to
um let's just call it downtown okay so
I'm like okay that's going to be 45
minutes it's a hot summer day yes I I'm
gonna get hot and I know when I'm hot
sometimes I get impatient yes and I get
stressed and I don't want to feel that
so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with Marie Brendan and really
just engage pay attention be present
with New York and really enjoy that
you're here I know that sounds
completely crazy but every High
performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it I mean a high level
every person I interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers they all self-talk and most
of them we found we're doing in second
and third
which is amazing I love it I think it's
so fun yeah little things yeah so if you
already talk to yourself and you say
your name to yourself and they're not
crazy you're probably high performing
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Jay Shetty check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there visualization the
recreation of images sounds and
environments before it has happened is
one of the most powerful skills in the
world a very powerful meditation and
mindfulness practice